in just the last two years we've taken
you on the journey into more than 250
hypothetical scenarios we've explored
what happens when you dump your trash
into a volcano when you get sucked into
a black hole or fall through the clouds
of Jupiter we've drained the world's
oceans built a ringed world in space and
terraformed as many planets as we could
we're on an epic journey to explore the
infinite possibilities in this universe
and imagine the unimaginable hopefully
you're learning along with us well sure
you are by now you probably know a ton
of different things but there's one
thing you don't know who's making all
these cool what-if videos and what do I
look like anyway hi I'm Eli musk some of
you might think that making what-if is a
one-man show
but that's certainly not the case let me
take you on a tour of our office what if
is a team of all kinds of crazy
creatures from researchers to video
producers to the people who keep the
lights on all these people play an
important role in continuing to bring
you videos about your three am thoughts
and we don't just sit at our desks we're
out here in the field testing the
craziest what-if ideas you can think of
so keep them coming
but we haven't even mentioned the most
important face of what if and that's you
without you watching sharing and
suggesting new ideas what if wouldn't be
the show that it is today
and that's not a hypothetical scenario
that's the truth so now that you've seen
some of the other people who work around
the office here what if I guess it's
time you saw my face for real this time
so if my trusty editor over here can
please remove the deep fake from my face
hi everyone I'm Peter I'm the voice of
what if and I'd like to thank you all
for watching our show throughout the
years it's really meant a lot to us and
it's really helped us get to where we
are today like I say I'm not the only
person who works on what if and I'm not
the only one who has something to say to
you
thank you for subscribing
thanks for watching and for liking
what would we do next well that's a
story for another what if oh and one
more thing you can now support this show
on patreon your support will help us
make better videos and produce more of
our own special effects as a patron you
can also vote on upcoming topics or help
script research and fact check our
episodes they'll be lots to see behind
the scenes you can chat with the team
and so much more go to the link of the
description to learn more about how you
can help by the way congrats everyone a
video where we didn't kill anyone
oh geez
[Music]